well
Ernesto ladies and gentlemen I'm doubly
delighted to be here at Yale this
afternoon firstly because I'm in the
company of my old friend Ernesto cydia I
have known President Sudhir for many
years and he is a one of a two rare
breed a man who gives politics a good
name so it's always a pleasure to see
him and it was a delight to accept his
invitation to visit this famous old
University once again and it's also a
special delight and privilege to deliver
the george herbert walker the third
lecture in my years in politics George
Herbert Walker Bush was a very close
ally notably during the first Gulf War
and became a lifelong friend to cherish
George Bush is a citizen of the world
and respected in every part of it well I
became prime minister George Bush was
the first person to phone me up from Air
Force One there was a slight glitch he
got my brother and the conversation went
slightly awry but he was the my brother
was wondering who he was and and said to
the cook in the kitchen there's a mr.
Bush on the phone do we know him and I
was dragged out mid adjacent room in
order to speak to the president and then
when I ceased to be prime minister
george bush was pretty much the first
person on the phone yet again with an
invitation to join him and barbara at
Kennebunkport George like Ernesto is a
friend for all seasons so for George and
honest so I do almost anything that I do
draw the line at jumping out of aircraft
on my birthday even for George now my
theme this afternoon is the quite
extraordinary ways in which the world is
changing and what that means for the
future and let me try and firstly put it
in some sort of context my father died
50 years ago
since then the world has changed beyond
recognition 50 years ago the Soviet
Union in the United States were the two
superpowers China was isolationist Japan
had barely begun her post-war rise
central and eastern europe was cylinder
Soviet control Germany was still a
divided nation Latin America was a
continent of revolutions the European
Union was in its infancy the Gulf was
undeveloped much of Africa was still
colonized oil oil was three dollars a
barrel and no one foresaw an Islamic
Revolution little of that world now
survives and the pace of change is
accelerating within the span of one
lifetime my father were he here would
simply not recognize today's world and
neither would people who left politics
quite senior politics much more recently
someone both George Bush and I knew very
well was Boris Yeltsin now Yeltsin ruled
russia 15 years ago but now seems in
many ways part of an age that is wholly
gone so much has changed Boris had a
great gift for any things among them
brevity and irony I remember walking
with him once in the Kremlin and we were
talking this would be in the mid-1990s
and I said to him Boris tell me in one
word what is the state of Russia he said
good
I was surprised it was falling to pieces
I said tell me in two words he said not
good however even since then the world
has moved on nothing is as it was and in
the future nothing will be as it is the
great challenge is to identify the
changes that are to come and use them
and try and take advantage of them now
you may say that we don't know what is
to come in fact we know a good deal more
about the future than we realize when
Shakespeare put the words nothing comes
from nothing into King Lia's mouth he
spoke an eternal truth change rarely
comes as a bolt from the blue it's a
result of trends we have overlooked or
sometimes policy that we have ourselves
implemented and I suppose as evidence of
that assertion I offer the economic
problems we've been facing in the last
couple of years they are the result of
an unrestrained boom business and
political leadership failed us we
enjoyed the boom but we did not prepare
for the aftermath and as a result the
outlook for all the mature economies
America Britain the eurozone Japan who
for this purpose and this purpose only
is an honorary Westerner the outlook for
the mature economies is at best sluggish
consumer demand is fragile banks are
cautious about lending as they repair
balance sheets public spending is anemic
unemployment is stubbornly high now this
is a result of policy failures and it
brings into stark relief a trend that
has been developing for decades other
economies in what we quaintly and rather
patronizingly called the third world
though I have myself
in 40 years of politics never discovered
what the second world is the third world
is catching up on the dominance that we
have enjoyed for so long China India
Brazil turkey Mexico Indonesia are all
coming into much greater prominence and
will continue to do so in the decades
that lie immediately ahead now as
Westerners we may regret a shrinking
preeminence but it does create a better
balanced and very probably a safer world
than we have previously known and in one
way the development of these new nations
their economic rise is very helpful to
us its emerging markets that will help
refloat the Western economies and it's
led to something I certainly never
expected to see in my lifetime China
funding the American deficit but you and
I had better get used to novelties like
that because the growth of the emerging
nations has now passed the point where
it is likely to be reversible and our
future world will be different wholly
different as a result of that now I
don't propose this afternoon though you
may at question time I don't propose
this afternoon to focus on economic
changes but we should note them the
growing flow of wealth from west to east
the growing role of sovereign wealth
funds which is huge the scramble for
commodities particularly perhaps in
Africa and the price inflation in them
that is very likely to follow all these
are trends already clearly signposted
for the future I do want just for a
moment though to touch upon the inter
dependence of nations where there is one
trend one mini trend that I hope is not
going to develop
over the past two decades the concept of
free trade has become almost universal
countries that once were collectivist
even communists embraced free enterprise
and prospered as a result of it the
impact of the financial crisis has put a
very large question mark over that
development in the minds of some of the
people running these countries a body
called global trade alert has reported a
very significant growth in trade
protection not sufficiently serious yet
for us to be neurotic about it but
sufficiently widespread to be worrying a
growth in protection that needs watching
because if more countries adopt
protectionist measures particularly if
they are big countries most particularly
of all if they happen to be the United
States then protection amongst trade
rivals will grow rivals will retaliate
and that could snowball and have a
significant effect on World Trade and
we'd be wise to remember that it wasn't
the Wall Street Crash in the lightened
late 1920s that caused the depression
throughout the 1930s it was the policies
of protection that followed the Wall
Street Crash that actually calls the
greatest damage and the growth of trade
for America for example world trade for
America did not get back to its pre Wall
Street Crash level for over two decades
so there is a problem there that we need
to keep a very close eye on now what I
would like to do is to look at the world
that is to come and I'd like to start
with the most basic issue of all mankind
itself in the 41 years since America
landed a man on the moon
world population has doubled doubled in
41 years it now grows by as much every
12 years as it grew in the nineteen
hundred years between the birth of
Christ and the dawn of the 20th century
now that is a startling statistic and a
very important one in many ways because
the trend is accelerating by 2050 and
there are many people in this room who
are going to be around in 2050 though
I'm not at all sure I will be among them
but by 2050 not very far away in
planning terms a world population will
soar to over 9 billion souls this is an
increase from today that is the
equivalent of two more China's
contemplate that these are not just
statistics they're people men women
children with hopes fears and missions
and needs needs for food water clothing
education housing jobs and every basic
of life and while we meet here this
afternoon pretty much one half of the
world goes hungry allege akay today
often without hope how much worse may
the problem be with an additional two
billion to care for ninety-five percent
of whom will be born in countries that
are very poor so planning for this world
needs to begin now politicians are so
often focused on what is immediately
ahead of them because you the electorate
demand that they are apart from their
own wish to be reelected but unless
around the world people begin to lift
their eyes and look at some of these
longer-term trends we are going to be in
very serious trouble when the
projections we can now say
become the reality that is the
day-to-day contemporary problem the
politics and nations begin themselves to
face now let me give you an illustration
of the sort of planning that needs to be
done already many parts of the Middle
East and North Africa face water
shortages water shortages for families
for agriculture and for industry in
North Africa the River Nile has been the
supply of water since the dawn of time
but the demands on the Nile will one day
become unsupportable consider this in
1905 million Sudanese depended upon the
Nile today it is over 42 million and by
2050 it will be a minimum of 50 million
and similar statistics not quite so
stark perhaps apply to every other
country alongside the Nile and the
relevance of this is that action is
required now to ensure adequate water in
30 or 40 years time and if no one begins
to act now the problem will be so great
that it will be too late when water
shortages become immediate and become
acute now these population projections
aren't fantasy they are reality but they
could become a nightmare unless we
prepare for now as population changes so
does the future of our world so does
technology my grandfather who was in
Pittsburgh in the 1860s and 1870s
helping to build the Carnegie steel
works my grandfather never conceived of
the combustion engine let alone
aeroplanes
he never conceived of the telephone let
alone mobiles and now we have rockets in
space and satellites and they arouse
almost no interest among the populace as
a whole so what is life going to be like
for our grandchildren given the change
is accelerating we can't know that we do
know the trend of change technology is
moving ever faster it's getting smaller
and more powerful it's getting cheaper
and more accessible it took the
telephone 50 years to reach one quarter
of the population of America 50 years
it's taken Facebook and Google less than
three years to reach every single corner
of the world now science isn't emotional
it deals in facts 700 years ago it told
as the earth there wasn't spherical and
was not the center of the universe at
the time the Christian Church killed
people for such heresy but science was
right and now science and technology is
the unstoppable motor that is changing
every aspect of our lives consider what
it has done the first integrated circuit
invented by a man called Jack Kilby at
texas instruments in 1958 proved to be
the forerunner of silicon chips
containing literally billions of
microscopic circuit elements nothing no
single invention in the 20th century so
accelerated change it led to the
computer revolution to the digital age
without that crude circuit board there
would be no Silicon Valley no internet
no laptop no Google no ipods no iPads no
blackberries no Playstations and none of
the hundreds of millions of jobs that
they created so who knows what
challenges
head perhaps for example to take one
example of many as a result of the
particle beams circulating in the Large
Hadron Collider at CERN in Switzerland
just last week just a few days ago
scientists captured antimatter for the
very first time although only a few
grains and only for one tenth of one
second but it had never happened before
and this may I emphasize may be a new
frontier it was antimatter you may
recall that powered the USS Enterprise
in Star Trek fantasy is becoming reality
now as science changes how we live
medical science is changing the quality
and the length of our lives 110 years
ago no one knew a blood groups or
hormones or barbiturates since then
medicine has given birth to whole new
industries new technologies are
delivering better drugs healthy food new
pesticides the control of pollution and
advances in forensic medicine technology
and medicine our old partners the first
man to assert that blood circulates and
is pumped from the heart was William
Harvey but it wasn't until the discovery
of the microscope in the 1650s that this
was verified by the determination that
there were tiny connections between
arteries and veins now in a modern
parallel scientists are examining how to
combine computer chip technology with
pharmaceutical research so they can
target drugs to treat specific parts of
the body imagine for example
chemotherapy so targeted to the root of
the problem that it had only minimal
side effects
now science like this is leading to a
revolution in medical care advances in
engineering techniques have given as
insulin pumps for diabetes cochlear
implants for deafness and there are
realistic prospects of repairing nerve
cells for sufferers of Parkinson's and
Alzheimer's disease it may soon be
possible to produce artificial heart
muscle cells and stem cell research stem
cell research may enable us to grow
replacement body parts experiments in
San Diego in laboratories in San Diego
have already grown a human bladder we
can expect further advances just about a
decade ago scientists mapped the human
genome system we are daily learning more
about how we live and why we die on the
day that mapping was announced I was
lunching with some eminent medical
surgeons at one of Britain's great
teaching hospitals Adam Brooks in
Cambridge and we talked about it what
does this mean I ask the scientists who
were gathered there and it means they
told me that medicine may determine in a
child how that child may die as an adult
and knowing that they can determine the
treatment that may delay that death
significantly the life span they added
for a new baby born in a country with an
advanced medical system that uses the
science that is now available the life
span for that baby may rise from the 79
to 81 years average of today to well
into the 90s consider the social and
other implications of that development
already life expectancy is rising for
four months
in every year it will accelerate now
just a few years ago all of this would
have seemed like black magic very soon
fantasy will become reality in a world
we are only barely beginning to glimpse
now change of course is almost always
two-faced sometimes it brings risk
sometimes it brings danger consider our
earth our blue and green planet it's
altered over the years continents have
drifted oceans have been formed Africa
and South America what's joined together
split asunder species have evolved and
become extinct now these changes
happened over literally hundreds of
millions of years but a few thousand
years ago like everything else in our
modern life it all began to speed up
agriculture began vegetation changed the
growing population began to deplete raw
and rare materials now in the last few
decades we began to emit radio waves
from television radar and cell phones
and carbon dioxide emissions have
absolutely sword planes have filled the
skies and missiles satellites and
spacecraft have been propelled beyond
our biosphere into orbit for the first
time in the long lifetime of the earth
our way of life can affect the future of
our planet now this is the defining
challenge for the future can we utilize
the science that is given as these
innovations to protect our way of life
from the effects of those innovations
and once more a single contemporary
example may suffice science tells us
that the risks of climate change are
real Arctic summer ice is disappearing
faster than we thought without it the
sea absorbs the Sun and melts the
permafrost that keeps the lid on
greenhouse gases the burning of fossil
fuels continues to raise dioxides most
not all that most scientists expect this
to lead to global warming of between two
and five degrees doesn't sound much does
it does it matter yes it does because
NASA tells us the when temperatures last
rose two to three percent which they did
35 million years ago sea levels rose by
25 meters even five meters would swamp
large parts of London New York Sydney
Vancouver Mumbai and Tokyo regions of
Florida Louisiana nevermind Bangladesh
and the Netherlands would vanish
Singapore would sink so no wonder green
energy is such a growing business but
here is the dilemma for the policymakers
our modern world is powered by energy
it's indispensable for political and
economic stability a world without
readily available energy is a world that
cannot power industry light homes cook
food drive cars it would be chaotic
without energy we return to life before
the Industrial Revolution it's
unthinkable and it's unimaginable now we
and by we I don't just mean this nation
the developed nations of the world have
been shamefully wasteful of our energy
resources in the last half century and
are now paying heavily for it I referred
to oil at three dollars a barrel it's
now 80 and rising as demand has grown
and grown and it won't slacken demand
cannot slacken as Latin America Africa
and Asia continue to industrialize and
as population continues to grow
so the role of science is going to be
pivotal it must mitigate the impact of
fossil fuel degradation and prepare for
the post fossil fuel age now this is
still many decades ahead of us but one
day it will come already science is far
advanced in effective measures of
capturing and storing carbon before it
leaks into the atmosphere although many
of the worst polluters around the world
haven't got or if they have got don't
utilize the technology that is now
available we're looking at alternative
sources of energy solar energy advanced
biofuels fusion other renewables all of
them have a role to play and so does the
safe expansion of nuclear power probably
a bigger role than any of the others
which an increasing number of nations
not least in the Middle East Sea is
essential to future prosperity and we
also need science to do something that
seems a little more mundane and that is
to finalize the electrical car to reduce
co2 emissions an estimated 100 million
cars are sold every year and there will
next year be an incredible 1 billion
cars on the planet an electric motor can
make a significant difference to the
emission of co2 now challenges like this
are daunting so is the cost but we dare
not ignore them if we take no action my
generation will be fine we won't be
seriously inconvenience but our children
and our grandchildren may face a
disastrous scenario now as we look ahead
there are acute political and social
challenges in nearly every nation in the
world the rising cost of caring for more
elderly people the provision of pensions
for them enrich
sufficient leisure and work to keep
minds occupied and life worthwhile such
challenges will do more than alter the
number and length of our lives they may
change almost everything that is
familiar to us now as we prepare for
what lies ahead it's reassuring to
recall the past challenges that have
been met for most of my life time the
world was at risk at risk because NATO
and the Warsaw Pact were facing one
another with nuclear arsenals that if
unleashed could destroy much of life as
we know it reason and wise politics not
least from past American presidents like
George Bush prevented such a catastrophe
today intercontinental carnage on that
sort of scale is very very very very
unlikely but if the world is safer the
dangers of proliferation of nuclear
weapons of regional conflicts and of
terrorism loom much larger as viable
risks Winston Churchill once referred to
Russia as a riddle wrapped in a mystery
inside an enigma much the same could be
said of Iran today since the flawed
re-election a president Ahmadinejad
there has been widespread internal
dissent by hundreds of thousands of
individual Iranians there had been
marches coded speeches intellectual
dissent as Liberty has raised its voice
and the regime has responded as we might
have expected with repression but like
others before them they will find that
the demand for change for something
better for a free and open society is
impossible to smother forever you cannot
arrest freedom and put it in jail but
the fear of a nuclear Iran is a real
fear
so is the effect of a nuclear on the
evil is not just that they have a weapon
that they might use the evil is that if
Iran obtains a weapon the risk of
proliferation is very very high indeed
Iran worries everyone and destabilizes
much of the Middle East now why is it
wrong doing this the economy is in a
mess the currency is weak inflation
interest rates and unemployment are all
very high it's a very sad come down for
a nation that had a great empire when
the British and Americans still lived in
mud huts now nothing is explicable in
Iran without understanding the nature of
the regime it is nationalist and
hardline and the real source of power is
a supreme leader backed by the
revolution regards the army the
intelligence services and the police the
President Ahmadinejad so often the face
of Iran is in truth a secondary figure
he's not the decisive decision maker too
many people overreact to his provocative
remarks without realizing his
subordinate position he's the apprentice
not the sorcerer the monkey not the
organ grinder so what should we do I
think first we remember the regime is
not the nation as the internal dissent
in Iran makes vividly clear and even so
while the clerical regime survives we
have to deal with it it is possible
negotiations may improve relations and
of course we should continue to try but
because of the threat she poses we must
supplement dialogue with incentives and
sanctions some advocate military
conflict and unattractive though that is
in every conceivable way we cannot
absolutely uninfected but for the time
being sanctions and political pressures
in the
right way forward and we can only hope
that they are sufficient and then of
course in the Middle East there's a
dispute the arab-israeli dispute that
colors the world's view of the Middle
East it spills beyond its own borders
and it has scarred politics for decades
and is it not absurd that we know the
two-state solution we seek but cannot
turn it into reality morality as well as
practicality says that we need a
solution after several decades a
bilateral negotiated settlement is still
far away many wonder whether it will
ever be possible attempts at incremental
agreements confidence-building in the
jargon have failed again and again and
again peace negotiations remember
nothing Ramon remind me of nothing so
much as a mating of the black widow
spider once the dance is over death and
destruction invariably follow how often
have we seen that and how damaging is it
both to Israel and the Palestinians and
the wider region the present situation
is close to stalemate Palestinians are
split secular fat our control the West
Bank Islamic Hamas rule in Gaza Hamas
deny the right of Israel even to exist
they won't renounce violence nor accept
previous agreements made by Palestinian
negotiators meanwhile Israel build
settlements that the world deems illegal
is there a solution of course the
obvious one a negotiated settlement but
if that can't be achieved if negotiators
from Israel and the Palestinians cannot
make the concessions necessary to
compromise because of their internal
politics what then
for how long can the international
community allow this dispute to run on
and on will the time come when the risk
becomes so great that in the wider
interests they have no choice other than
to press more firmly their own ideas for
a settlement the protagonists would hate
this understandably we would if we were
in their position but if both sides take
positions at impede progress what
alternatives exist for the impact of
this dispute spreads more widely than
simply in their own territories will it
be difficult of course it will it's a
gamble a high toss of the coin and one
that will require great political
courage with all concerned but in the
Middle East as much as anywhere and more
importantly than in most parts of the
world statesmanship is essential if the
region is to fulfill its potential
without fear of conflict and if Israel
is remained to remain safe in the
decades that lie ahead now one conflict
is now worldwide it's important to
understand that terror al Qaeda being an
example threatens Muslim societies as
much as in some cases more than
Christian societies al Qaeda hate the
Saudi Arabians more than they loathe the
Americans the British and the Europeans
the Taliban two would change society
back to pre enlightened days with a
rigid approach to religion and civil
life that is abhorrent to most people we
have seen vivid and terrifying examples
of that intolerance recently in both
Iran and Pakistan the concept of stoning
a woman to death or executing another
because she actually had the temerity to
advocate and be proud of her
Christianity is something that to us
seems to come out of an age many
centuries ago that still exists in parts
of the world now this battle against
intolerance and
and unreason is one in which every state
has an interest it isn't a short-term
conflict nor one capable of a clear-cut
finite ending it is too complex too
chaotic for that but it is one from
which no nation can safely exclude
itself we all have an interest in the
outcome for it is our future that will
be scarred unless we find solutions to
these problems let me before we turn to
questions offer one final thought about
the future sometimes in politics and in
life it's necessary to stand back and
take stock now is such a moment our
world has many complexities but more
opportunities if we arrange our affairs
to take advantage of them our future can
be so much more promising than even the
most pessimistic can believe sometimes I
think we should be more aware more
self-confident of what we can do young
men and women today here at this
university will do things see things
know things be things that their parents
and grandparents would never have
dreamed of we must make sure that they
can take advantage of those
opportunities much of what I've had to
say in the last few minutes has been
about science so let me conclude with a
quote from the man Voltaire called the
father of modern science in the preface
to his essays Francis Bacon a
philosopher in Elizabethan England
observed and I quote we have planted
things that are likely to last we have
planted things that are likely to
last so have we in our time planted
things that are likely to last
throughout history change has been an
ally in the future if we are wise it
will continue to be so thank you very
much